emotions ran high at the rally in El
Paso near the hospital the president
visited a crowd of more than 300
gathered and triple-digit heat to
remember the people who had died and
leaned on each other for support more
than 80% of El Paso's population is
considered Hispanic or Latino with
tensions rising throughout the country
we asked some of those people how the
politics and rhetoric in Washington are
affecting them also how the community
can move on after Saturday's violent
attack to have an outsider coming into
this us for no reason besides our color
of our skin from where we come from it's
just unbelievable we're all definitely
on edge a little more scared nowadays
because of what happened at that Walmart
there's a sense of fear when you leave
your house which wasn't here originally
in El Paso
my engineers brought me to this country
to give me a better opportunity siena
taken away we're kind of affected
because of the immigration and Trump's
reform on immigration and it has done
harm to El Paso until he started coming
here and calling us Hispanic rapist in
gangsters
and he brought this attention to us he
put a target on us and now all these
people are dead we are all scared
because we were worried that it could
happen again we run into people that are
positive in spite of what happened and
we're looking forward to positive
changes hopefully coming from this
tragedy but it's something that will
never be for God and no matter what
happens in our next half hour
award-winning journalist in CBS News
contributor
Maria Elena Salinas will tell us what
she's hearing from Hispanic communities
in El Paso and across the nation